In Java you can use an interface type to describe common behavior. In our
example, what do cars and dogs and houses have in common, they're all drawable.
They all have a draw method. In Java, we use the interface keyword instead of
the class keyword. To define interfaces. Here we say that Drawable is an
interface, with a draw method. We give no implementation of the draw method,
that's up to the individual classes, that implement this interface. Methods in
an interface are automatically public. You can write the keyword public, or you
can omit it. Now an interface is different from a class, an interface only
specifies the behavior and you can't create objects of an interface, instead
you create objects of classes that implement the interface, let's look at that
next.